[Musique]
on se sent bien dans l'atmosphère de
cette vieille ferme de l'île d'oléron
adèle qu'est-ce que vous avez
l'intention de nous préparer pour
déjeuner alors un poulet aux huîtres
c'est intéressant ce serait bien alors
voilà ce qu'il me faut il me faut dans
le poulet il me faut dans les huit
il me faut dans de l'huile et du beurre
pour le faire cuire de la crème fraîche
avec le vin blanc pour faire la sauce le
sel le poivre le persil elle est aussi
pour le tartiner les huit ce poulet
adèle comment avez vous choisi alors
premièrement comme poids de 1 kg 500
pour 6 personnes c'est ce qu'il ya de
très copieux mais on peut le mettre pour
huîtres les huîtres maintenant alors
c'est l'huître de claire qui est la
meilleure photo meilleur pour ça le
capteur personnes ce qui fait à peu près
de 12 ans voilà ce poulet adèle vous
allez le faire cuire tel quel comme ça
non je vais le découper oui elle le
faire sauter à la poêle
c'est pas toujours facile de découper un
pool r il faut savoir où le prendre mais
si bien vous savez savez si vous me
demandiez à moi j'sais pas sûr d'y
arriver du premier coup c'est faisable
oui
et ça va donner six ou sept ou huit
belles paribas je fais ça aux ciseaux
pour ne pas couper les os voilà tous mes
morceaux et maintenant alors maintenant
je vais dans les faire frire
voilà voilà
[Musique]
en dépit de la proximité des charentes
poitou et de son célèbre beurre au goût
de noisette
mademoiselle adele a choisi de faire
frire ses morceaux de poulet dans de
l'huile
[Applaudissements]
mais
ne dérangeons pas mademoiselle adèle
visiblement très absorbé par sa
préparation
et précisons qu'elle va conserver au
chaud les morceaux de poulet bien grillé
reviendra à dell maintenant que le
poulet et bien grillé bien beau qu'est
ce qu'on fait alors je perds pour les 8
je mets un petit peu de vin blanc dans
le fond de la casserole
je mets mes huit bien à plat bien
entendu comme ça je recouvre m'avait
apporté au feu il va falloir les faire
chauffer celle-là elle et fait rouvrir
[Musique]
voilà tout se présente bien le poulet
est au chaud les huîtres sont en train
de s'ouvrir
on peut en profiter pour perdre quelque
chose je continue ce jeu des graisses un
petit peu ma ma poil voilà en en
laissant un petit peu et puis à l'heure
h mon père c'est maintenant
oui c'est intéressant de pouvoir garder
lui qui a servi à faire à faire autre
chose le poulet parce que cette huile a
fait cuire le reste quoi elle a déjà un
bon goût et voilà voilà bien
ça va servir à faire des petites aussi
les petites où on va poser les 8 10 et
11 heures à la pendue c'est bientôt
l'heure de déjeuner voilà combien de
temps prendra la préparation dans
l'ensemble adel au j'avais on n'atteint
pas trois quarts d'heure je m'aime
légaux à la tête
en effet elles se sont ouvert se sont
ouverts dites-moi d'air c'est quoi un
petit peu dommage de faire cuire les
huîtres on hésite peut-être non non
parce que je vous dis que ce qu'elles
sont mais le meilleur 1
ce que je sais faire ça fait rien c'est
une habitude dans l'île d'oléron et
avrillé mots pour beaucoup évidemment
ils sont beaucoup plus faciles à ouvrir
une fois chaude l'homme que fois c'est
qu'il faut le garder précieusement ce
jus on sert tout ça qu'est bon avons
plus que doublé de la can il ça va
servir à quoi de la fair le jus pour un
rosé le pool v
alors regardez que j'en ai pas beaucoup
mais c'est ce qu'il faut maintenant
alors qu'en europe les gros temps
maintenant je perds au comptant et cette
fois pas d'hésitation c'est le beurre
qui servira à faire frire les croûtons
[Musique]
voilà
et l'on arrive au moment délicat de
cette recette c'est à dire la
préparation de la sauce aux huîtres
il faut d'abord faire revenir ses
huîtres à la poêle
voilà c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
puis on ajoute le jus de cuisson de ses
huîtres ainsi qu'une bonne cuillerée de
crème fraîche elle est bien belle déjà
alors il est temps d'ajouter quoi
maintenant alors je sais tout juste là
et puis alors un petit peu de poids que
vous avez là voilà surtout pas de ça
serait pas de sel parce que je vous dis
ce petit jules à est venu y avoir assez
de jus pour expliquant je suis contre 2
me voilà très très salée alors
maintenant je vais et reformer le poulet
et elle met mes gars jouaient sur
mécontents et remettent elles maintenant
30 ans tout autour de blanc donc tout
est prêt il ya plus qu'un vrai dressé
voilà au magnifique
cette nouvelle présentation
alors maintenant une ou deux huîtres je
vois par comptons de pain vous attendez
pour rappel vous emmener de parier
[Musique]
fils et deux qui finissent la soudure
van essen comme sauce alors on la
première le pool voilà il va falloir
servir cela très vite et bien assez
chaude et me voilà qu'est ce que c'est
que cette belle assiette que vous avez
préparé adèle pas les huîtres avec les
saucisses
c'est spécial ça ben non dans notre
contrée c'était indispensable
on appelle ça la crépinette oléronnaise
s'il vous plaît et ça se mange à une
certaine période de l'année a toujours
toujours toujours toujours ceux là qui
sont pas riches bien entendu qu'il n'en
met pas le récitant mais dites moi vous
avez mis votre belle coiffe dès dimanche
aussi et cette coiffe à un nom
particulier la quichenotte ans les
rennaises qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça
eh bien je ne sais pas parce que c'est
vous en voyez pas dans le continent des
kiss note comme ça non non vous envoyer
avec du tissu à fleurs vous savez puis
qu'on fait de la dentelle des choses
comme ça mais ça c'était vraiment vous
dites de ce temps-là tu as fait au moins
je suis pas 110 ans vous savez que qu'il
est là
[Musique]